well this is what gold nights fans are
more importantly the Knights themselves
have been looking forward to for a long
time a return to the ice team is back at
City national getting ready for a
postseason that will begin in August
Vegas and the rest of the West will be
isolated in Edmonton and if the Knights
play the way they should and reach the
Cup final well they'll be away from
their loved ones for nearly two months
yeah I mean it's fine an ideal situation
for sure why I mean the whole situation
is not ideal not just for us but for
everybody so I mean it's it's just kind
of the new world we're living in and
everybody's set up and we're
professional hockey players we gotta
earn earn we signed contracts and we get
our paychecks and I mean at some point
it's when it comes to platf it's all
about just winning and getting your
number and your name on the cup alright
Knights might be in Edmonton for a while
they are the favorite in the West to
reach the Stanley Cup final now Kevin E
Martin was that City national for
today's first day at Camp
hey in caveny we are all envious because
I'm pretty sure it's about 60 degrees
inside that building today yeah Chris
I'll tell you what it felt really good
but it's been four months in one day
since the NHL suspended its play
indefinitely
amid the corona virus pandemic and now
Phase three or otherwise training camp
began today here at city national arena
of course fans were not permitted inside
the building in media access was
severely limited but the Golden Knights
the whole team not just a small group
skated on the ice for the first time
since March and to think this is head
coach Pete de Bourgh's first training
camp definitely give us the guys a
chance to freshen up on his schemes and
regain that momentum they had built
right up before the pause where they
have won 11 of their last 13 games you
know our message to the group today was
I really like how we were playing going
into the pause I thought you know our
systems were in a good place we were
starting to play seamlessly we were we
were able to plug guys in and out of the
lineup and not lose a step so how do we
get back to that again
you know for me like any camp it's about
starting with your foundation again and
and getting to that point hopefully it
comes a little bit easier because you
know we were there three four months ago
when we paused and they know what that
feels like so that's the goal teams will
start on August 1st but the Golden
Knights aren't scheduled for their first
contests until August third against the
Dallas Stars an important to point out
one notable absence from the ice today
was Marc Andre flurry and when head
coach Pete de Bourgh was asked about
this at the press post practice press
conference via zoom he said he wanted to
squash any speculation it had nothing to
do with the positive tests or anything
like that he was just giving his veteran
goaltender a maintenance day reporting
live Kevin E Martin 8 Schwartz now they